desde primera hora de la mañana los
rusos han estado guardando Cola en esta
calle frente al edificio de la casa de
los sindicatos en el salón de columnas
está expuesto el cuerpo de mihahir
gorbachov fallecido en el pasado martes
Vladimir Putin cuya oficina está a unos
cientos de metros de este lugar ha
excusado su asistencia por motivos de
agenda y decidió despedirlo hace días en
el hospital donde falleció
gorbachov si se ha visto al ex
presidente ruso dimitriever actual
número 2 del Consejo de Seguridad del
país y algunos diputados también la
cantante rusa a la purgachova muchos
rusos la mayoría de unos 50-60 años se
han acercado con flores para despedir al
hombre que puso final a la unión
soviética pero que según recordaban
muchos asistentes esta mañana logró
hacerlo sin violencia sin que existiese
una guerra civil gorbachov no tendrá
final de estado será enterrado no junto
ideas del crimen como otros líderes
soviéticos sino en el cementerio de
novochi junto a su esposa No vais cheva